[Música]
hoy se conmemora el día internacional de
la desaparición forzada que es cuando
las personas desaparecen de su entorno
familiar y de su comunidad sin dejar
rastro esto se da cuando agentes
estatales o con el consentimiento del
estado las detienen por una calle o por
su casa y después llegan o rehúsan decir
dónde se encuentran se trata de un
delito de derecho internacional a menudo
estas personas nunca son puestas de
nuevo en libertad y no llega a conocerse
su paradero
muchas de estas víctimas sufren tortura
y viven con el temor constante de que
las maten y saben que su familia
desconocen por completo su ubicación y
que no es probable que alguien acuda en
su ayuda salvamos entonces a la luz
marina monzón ella es directora de la
unidad de búsqueda de personas dadas por
desaparecidas en colombia además es
abogada luís marín un gusto tenerla en
nuestro estudio de directo américa de
france 24 gracias por estar con nosotros
muchas gracias raúl a ti a toda la
audiencia un saludo muy especial en
nuestra región a luz marina digamos para
poner un contexto primero pues general
cuáles son estos países que más sufren
de estas desapariciones forzadas
los países que en ese momento
vergonzosamente dan una unas cifras
bastante grandes de desaparición son
colombia en primer lugar méxico brasil
son los países con mayor reportes de
desaparición pero también se ha
presentado la desaparición forzada en el
continente en argentina en chile en
uruguay
el mismo perú que fue luego
del conflicto se hizo una comisión de la
verdad que dio cuenta de más de 20.000
personas desaparecidas durante el
conflicto armado pero como te das cuenta
esta no es una cifra que se compare con
las dimensiones cuantitativas de
colombia que tiene más de 100 mil
desaparecidos y de méjico que está por
los 100 mil desaparecidos pero estas
cifras no pueden verse como una cifra
cerrada de hecho lo a lo que se enfrenta
en la comprensión de este crimen tan
atroz es a un altísimo su registro un
altísimo su registro que está basado no
solamente en que las instituciones no
han focalizado una atención prioritaria
sobre este crimen sino que también hay
una dispersión de información y tercer
lugar una profunda desconfianza e
inseguridad de las víctimas en relación
con la institucionalidad porque como
bien lo dijiste al inicio la
desaparición forzada en general está
asociada a acciones del propio de
agentes del propio estado que son
quienes deben proteger a las personas
pero que terminan involucrados en la
eliminación de personas a través de la
desaparición forzada eso le quería
preguntar por qué llama la atención que
estas desapariciones forzadas son
digamos auspiciadas por el estado de
manera directa o indirectamente porque
digamos la comunidad internacional
no actúa de una manera más fuerte contra
estos responsables además quienes son
verdaderamente los responsables que se
está haciendo en estos países colombia y
méxico por ejemplo como bien lo decía
serán los principales para poder reparar
las víctimas para dar justicia digamos y
tranquilidad no solamente de las
personas que toda la vida se van a
quedar esperando y preguntándose dónde
está su ser querido si nunca van a cesar
de preguntar qué pasó con su ser querido
y van a morir exigiendo saber qué pasó
con sus seres queridos y quiero decir
esto que me parece muy importante y es
que este sufrimiento al que se somete a
una víctima cuando desaparecen a sus
seres queridos es un sufrimiento que
transgeneracional porque porque los
hijos los nietos los sobrinos crecen
viendo a esa persona que busca sufriendo
y seas y asume la tarea de la búsqueda
aún después de la muerte de estas
personas que buscaron durante toda su
vida pasando a lo que qué hace la
comunidad internacional la comunidad
internacional creo que a sea
dispuesto no solamente a reconocer este
crimen y hasta a sancionarlo a través de
de
decisiones como los tratados
internacionales donde los estados se han
comprometido a luchar en contra de la
desaparición forzada de personas en el
mundo sino que también creo que tiene
mecanismos que deben atender las
solicitudes de búsqueda pero también la
investigación sobre los desaparecidos
forzados estamos hablando del sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos del
sistema de naciones unidas y justamente
quiero conectar esto con lo que es la
conmemoración de este día del 30 agosto
las naciones unidas en el 2006 aprobó la
convención internacional contra contra
la desaparición forzada y en esta
convención e incluyó el día 30 como el
día internacional de reconocimiento no
solamente de que esto es inaceptable y
que no debe seguir pasando sino también
creo yo también reconoció el valor la
valentía la dignidad y la resistencia de
las víctimas que buscan a sus seres
queridos
por eso una de las obligaciones que
plantea esta convención que de manera
particular que no se tenía en otros
tratados internacionales es que los
estados tienen el deber de buscar a las
personas y entonces que existe un
derecho de las víctimas a buscar y que
hay un derecho del desaparecido a ser
buscado y creo que es muy importante y
por eso la unidad ha pedido al gobierno
colombiano a este nuevo gobierno que
ratifique la competencia del comité
contra las desapariciones forzadas que
se produce a se aprobó en esta
convención de la que acabo de mencionar
y digamos que bueno con lo que está
diciendo ha sido un palo en arranque
sentido si el estado les desaparece como
entonces después uno le pide la justicia
el estado y que el estado las busque qué
pasa allí o sea depende digamos de cada
administración o por ejemplo no sé en el
méxico en méxico también con los
estudiantes del sena para que en
colombia con el conflicto armado que
usted más de 100.000 personas
desaparecidas si el estado o la
complicidad del estado también les
desaparece como el estado de a buscar y
como el estado como la persona mejor
dicho confían en la justicia del estado
ese es el gran desafío o sea si el
estado está comprometido en las
desapariciones el primer obstáculo al
que se enfrentan las víctimas en la
profunda desconfianza la inseguridad de
que como ese mismo estado va a
verdaderamente proteger las cuales qué
es lo que plantea
como garantía digo yo la a las víctimas
la respuesta del estado los cambios de
administración es cambios de
administraciones como los que estamos
teniendo en este país que se comprometen
para poder remediar esas esas deudas
históricas en que no han asumido otras
administraciones y que han relegado esta
tarea y que no han atendido a las
víctimas y creo que esta administración
al menos tenemos esa esperanza esta
administración se comprometa a fondo con
la búsqueda a los desaparecidos y creo
que la administración de que firmó el
acuerdo de paz también tomó una paso muy
importante y es crear un mecanismo por
primera vez en colombia dedicado
exclusivamente a la búsqueda y hacerlo
de manera humanitaria y extrajudicial y
creo que ha sido una decisión tan
importante de términos de cumplimiento
de los compromisos internacionales y de
garantía de los derechos de las víctimas
que hoy en día la unidad ha recibido
cerca de nueve mil solicitudes de
búsqueda de personas que nunca habían
acudido a ninguna institución del estado
eso es muy significativo muy
significativo porque creo que esa
confianza se va ganando no se va ganando
a medida que hay unas condiciones de
institucionalidad que se compromete
verdaderamente con esta tarea pero que
también trabaja con ellos que hace el
trabajo con ellas que las escucha que
las acompaña y las asesora en esa
búsqueda y eso lo que viene haciendo la
unidad y creo que ir dando resultados es
esclareciendo lo que ha pasado va dando
la confianza luís marín a quienes son
las personas el grupo de población
digamos que sufren más de estas
desapariciones forzadas bueno las
desapariciones forzadas en un contexto
como el colombiano que se ha prolongado
durante décadas esta práctica es decir
no estamos hablando como los períodos de
las dictaduras en latinoamérica donde tú
podías ubicar en un periodo histórico es
preciso las desapariciones en colombia
tenemos un periodo de al menos
1948 hasta hoy de desapariciones
forzadas entonces cuando la prolongación
del tiempo mantiene una práctica de
éstas tú tienes que entrar a la
clarificación de cuáles son los hitos
históricos de la desaparición para saber
no solamente cuáles fueron los métodos
de desaparición sino quienes estuvieron
involucrados y cuáles fueron las
personas objeto de la desaparición
entonces nosotros hemos venido
identificando al menos tres hitos
históricos de la desaparición el de los
70 y los 80 y qué es la desaparición
forzada
desarrollada por agentes del estado
dirigida principalmente por quienes se
consideraban que eran insurgentes o
personas que apoyaban a los insurgentes
personas que fueron detenidas torturadas
y desaparecidas y luego viene el periodo
entre el 9 85 y 90 principios del 90 que
son las desapariciones que el estado
empieza a desarrollar conjuntamente con
grupos guerrilleros con grupos
paramilitares y ahí está ahí hay un se
amplía el grupo de personas a las cuales
se dirige la desaparición que se
extiende la zona rural que se es no
solamente se queda en la zona urbana
sino zonas rurales desaparecen personas
que están en partidos políticos de
izquierda
y también campesinos que están
reclamando sus derechos líderes sociales
y luego viene esta etapa tan horrorosa
que es la que se ha denominado
equivocadamente como 'falsos positivos'
pero que en el derecho internacional son
ejecuciones arbitrarias y es detener a
personas para mostrar resultados
positivos y por lo tanto un mensaje que
se está ganando el conflicto pues
lamentablemente se me acaba el tiempo ya
tengo que despedir me hubiera encantado
tener más tiempo con ustedes pero
seguramente más adelante le vamos a
tener un abrazo y gracias por estar esta
mañana con nosotros en directo américa
de francés y cuatro para el sistema tan
delicado y que es por eso importante
resaltar y es muy importante para la
construcción de paz muchas gracias mi
respeto mi saludo a la dignidad y
resistencia de miles y miles de víctimas
que buscan a sus seres queridos gracias
gracias a ti y los molina monsón
director a la unidad de búsqueda de
personas dadas por desaparecidas en
colombia además abogado